all right and we are live all right
little podcast launching gaming.net I am
Laura Cognito and who is this fine
gentleman in the realm of PAX East today
yeah
um I'm creative director for the uh my
name is
my name is
always
and then I saw your text message
good and now what do you have to
Showcase to us today well we have the F5
series X
basketball finally the Xbox Community
has their turn-based game that we've
been waiting for a long term so tell us
what how has the process been to get the
uh
transport over to console for PC to
Costco well uh for PC
it hasn't been many like a limitation so
you know video memory and so we worked
on a lot on
be here at around a few friends of
tournaments games you know one of the
things about lost islands that I really
like is that too well with a kind of a
cinematic culture
folks still have the accountable aspect
but as you see it Lord had to play right
now once you come back you see like
archers fighting people with you know
axes and swords and you see that
interaction almost like a baroque
says
cinematic approach to turn based well
um like that triangle thing
right and so
we wanted to create a you know rear like
like for this photo view there's only
like a character but when it goes to
into that kind of
to do that because they give that sense
of like a grand scale more a combat
another thing that I feel is a nice
touch that you guys don't get enough
credit for is what you were saying
explain like the ax versus the armored
character sword that what does it
actually said leather armor right
leather armor and then arrows and
archers are better against leather armor
yeah
nice
awesome awesome looking good now as far
as the cinematics and stuff in the story
about like any changes anything that
you've learned since this crisis will
last a little bit
well when we actually lost on PC we had
a lot of negative feedback
because
like giving us
a background yes so we walked on really
hard
have been fixed so that you know what
about four there was only like a
background and yeah yes yes
but then now that there are
they are supposed to try to understand
okay cool that's really cool because of
course that one of the most underrated
aspects of those islands that you guys
so I didn't really tell a good story and
to see you guys can take your feedback
from the community is really good are
there any other changes or any other
lessons that you got to learn in
development
was saying that
it's a tough based game why do we have
the ton of mini
ature there are people talking
[Music]
to
people who are really open
now just right here are we considered a
wall scrub to detained house camera well
this isn't really both for the the
monsters and monsters have a different
aspect of you know
you know
got you
I love what we're seeing here as far as
gameplay out what are we looking at now
and maybe total length as a person can
talk to finish maybe if they kind of
Mainline the game Let's gameplay
we have a 27 chapters oh wow so if you
just play through it's going to be like
a more than
post
okay good to see you guys still continue
so again we're coming to console Xbox
series X PlayStations are yeah okay
right so we're trying to do a
simultaneous console walls
okay cool cool and ideally what maybe
what time frame are we thinking uh
ideally I hope it's going to be thunder
oh that's okay okay
across the players
I remember playing
the strollers
it's called fighting in terms so for
example
the person who's the aggressive usually
gets the first slash the first attack
Ed to respond
to say okay even even though the person
will be aggressor in the
damage
you know I kind of thought that was
interesting what was the mindset behind
that what um the response attack yeah we
could we could have done like you know
you
you know yeah yeah
actually I think it's a unique decision
I actually like it it feels realistic
because again you still have to be
tactical another thing I like is it
really big we appreciate archers because
arches could come if you if you get
strategic you can place them Behind
Enemy you know certain you have other
units and they they sometimes they will
have they won't be able a lot of person
won't be able to respond to them so I
thought that was unique in that design
with the archers
also you're getting close so again for
people who want to learn more about it
support lost I bonds and support the
console version where can they go what
can they do well we have a PC version
available so you can go to
yes or we have all
four guys
so we have a city from
now are we still deck ready so where it
is a team that verified yes yes so we
verified on Steam that and again
potentially summer Xbox series consoles
PlayStation 5 potentially after that
lost I lost we are super excited to
finish live and uh you know maybe your
Xbox The Game Pass and uh I'll put you
in the service
but even so even so it's coming to
console got to support turn-based I'm
the lord of the turn-based community I
have to support especially making trying
things in the genre that are doing and
again the response combat is Cinematic
approach
I thought that's great and I'm pulling
for you guys so it's good to see you
again in the realm of packs lost I lost
anything else you want to tell the
people before we go all right we're
working hard on the console version and
we will keep
going to make a Tom based game so
nice nice Ocean Drive the Lords of turn
race iron Lord podcasts Lost Islands
coming to console Xbox series actually
has first and then PS5 go check that out
lost islands in the building
foreign